hi I'm Linda Kate Smith and I am a
lecturer in the engineering school here
at Stanford in particular I have the
opportunity to teach global
entrepreneurial marketing and I'm part
of the Fenwick and West educator program
that's my favorite part of my job and
then I also have a day job where I am
actually the chief marketing officer
which is also a great job chief
marketing officer for a start-up in the
city called twilio
how did I get to Stanford in the School
of Engineering really it started back I
think seven or eight years ago I had the
opportunity to meet Tom cosmic who is
one of the professors that I get to work
with and he actually had two of my heads
of product management as students back
in the global entrepreneurial marketing
program and they linked us up and it was
a great opportunity for me to get
involved with Stanford and I have had
the opportunity now to be teaching in
the winter and spring courses ever since
then and so it's been a great
partnership
so I have been doing the full and end
process of marketing them for way more
years than I would ever want to admit
but the reality is it really got me
excited it was an area that I could
apply so many different things too I
loved psychology i loved how people
think i had a creative bent i love the
creative aspects of what marketing
provides I had business background and
had graduated from a business school and
just loved how all of it had come
together it was the creative it was a
psychology it was the business and it
has been fascinating to watch what's
happened across marketing across those
many years of my career and the biggest
change I would say that we have seen is
really what's happened with the whole
advent of social the web was kind of
kind of a cool new thing and we all
thought that was the big thing but now
with social it has completely changed
how we market it's changed from how we
gather information and requirements and
understand our marketplace we have so
much more access than we ever did it has
changed the way we fundamentally reach
out and communicate with the audience's
that we're trying to work with it's
changed the nature of selling we can
actually leverage customers to do so
much more around the selling and it's
really changed how we're supporting
customers as well so you know in terms
of my opportunity I've gotten to see
marketing from back in the old days of
it was all about control and learning
how to control the message and was the
more traditional marketing to getting to
play in that wonderful web world that
came around which is still a part of it
now into the social so it's been a
vastly interesting journey and I'm
passionate about marketing
well I like to think of the things as
not maybe completely failing but if
you're to ask me one that got close to
the failure break was working for a
company here a startup company and it
became clear that what we had to offer
became very commoditised in the
marketplace and we were in a price
battle with her competitors on an
everyday basis and we hadn't even
crossed the chasm yet it was still a
very new area and because of that pre
commoditization we had to shift
strategies and one of the things I've
always been very involved with as a
marketer is the company's strategy the
market strategy really kind of that up
front part of the end-to-end process and
so had the responsibility for helping
the company shift and change the
strategy so we moved up the stack so to
speak if you're a software follower and
we went from being just a core
technology to having a full solution a
whole product that went really well we
got the right product got it to market
was really well received the piece that
was an experiment that didn't maybe work
as well as i would have liked it to is
that we also had a shifter selling from
being an indirect sales team joest
direct sales team and what i really
learned out of that is when you change a
strategy as fundamentally as we did
everything has to hit and while we took
precautions to try to make sure that
everything would hit we didn't finely
tuned it enough so it was a great lesson
learned the end game was fine the
company did wonderfully it's now an over
billion dollar revenue company so at the
end of the day I was a happy story
I think I would label myself probably
more of an innovator and the reason for
that is the fact that I love solving the
really tough business problems and so in
doing that you can do that at any stage
of the life cycle of a company and I
think when you look at innovation for a
company to be successful it needs to be
continually innovating so I like that
process of solving the tough problems to
renovation I think intrapreneurship is
fascinating it's why I work in an early
stage startup but when I think of what
my own skills are in my own love it's
really that constant innovation as
opposed to just innovation at the front
end